SOG I forgot about
that all right so this is the waiting
for sleep I didn't want to hear that all
right well this is the thing so I don't
go to shows really I just don't go
especially Comics I have no interest but
I happen to love Bill Burr I I he's
angry you know I love that kind of
Comedy so we're sitting in New York at
our place and K he goes oh Bill Bar's
going to be at uh an arena I always
forget the name of it in Newark New
Jersey I go when she goes tonight now I
know Bill saw me and decided to do
comedy when he saw me at the um I did
three nights in Boston at one the Arenas
there I just forgot the name right now
not the garden and uh no didn't do the
Boston Garden I always say the name of
that place
the Centrum the Boston Centrum okay you
know where he talked about this after on
his podcast that he was second row it
all the way up in the back right you
know and saw me and decided to do
standup so so I text Bill I go would you
mind if I come to your show tonight you
know if it feels weird I don't have to
come because just like with Rodney
Rodney's the guy that put me on top you
know what I mean so if he texted me dice
I'm coming ah Rodney's coming I gotta be
good you know what I mean I feel the
pressure with that but he wrote back
something to the effect of I want you to
come okay so I was excited you know I I
haven't been to a comedy concert forever
you know I've been I saw Rodney when I
in in 90 you know in Atlantic City I saw
Billy gell at Treasure Island about 15
years ago and that's it I just don't go
to comedy shows you know so I show up I
come in the dressing room and he just
gets up and he's got this smile on you
know and he goes you're GNA do some time
tonight right
Dice and I'm looking at him because I've
been talking to my agents that even
though I'm doing these smaller theaters
2,000 seats for me Isn't it's nothing
it's easy you know after everything I
did over 300 Arena shows I did the Rose
Ball with Guns and Roses
103,000 people so I've done the biggest
things you could do but not in two and a
half decades basically you know and he
doesn't know my problems physically you
know and I go ah you know I just I just
really want to I want to see you you
know he goes no you you got to do some
time
so it was funny cuz on the way there I'm
teasing my girlfriend going oh it's been
years since I've done an arena this and
that you know and she's going you're not
going to perform I go no you know this
is going to be a big night you know I'm
kidding her but she says to me I don't
know maybe you know cuz I could always
fool she goes maybe he ask you to
introduce him you know I go whatever you
know but now it's real now he's in my
face going you're going to do time so
what am I going to say I can't you know
I said well maybe I could introduce you
I'm using a line
so so now Club sorta Kenny who was My
Bodyguard Road manager for many years he
works with Bill you know now all of a
sudden Here Comes club soda going okay
you're on like right after Dean Del re I
was going on you know and now we're
walking towards the arena and I'm like
all right just do what you do you know
and I I it was scary to me I'll admit it
so Club sod is introducing
me his intro was great go get ready to
be Star
Struck which made me laugh you know he
goes the Undisputed heavyweight comedy
Andrew Dice Clay and the place
exploded like they don't know him there
right you know and I go up and honestly
once I was on I could have done two
hours wow you know and I did I gave bill
this incredible intro you know but he
said that your words of encouragement
were great because I asked him he was
here and and asked him about playing the
Boston Garden you know which was his
homecoming he's a Boston kid and that's
the he also did Fenway Park oh Fenway
not the Boston gardenway Parkway Park
and he said that you really encouraged
him and helped him get through that that
you texted him you know what happened
I'm getting ready you ever do par Casino
in Philly um maybe okay I forget but
it's a it's a pretty new casino I love
it CU of the way they have it set up
it's brand new so my phone rings I'm
getting dressed and I see it's bill so I
talked to him about like you know and
talking about the Fenway thing I go I'm
trying to get dressed as Eleanor's on
stage right now you know but we talk for
like 20 what are you going to wear you
know I go you know it's a special thing
you know all of that stuff do you gave
him clothing advice yeah which which
when I was on the phone with him
recently I go I hope I didn't overstep
by bringing up thething thing who knows
I never saw it yet I go I hope I didn't
overstep with the clothing he goes do
you understand that's coming from a guy
wearing fingerless gloves and and shorts
that a three-year-old wears normally you
know so it's just a big laugh speaking
of your shorts and your fingerless
gloves I've been loving you on Tik Tock
yeah I have been loving you